[Music]
our first look at bachelor Winter Games
is here bachelor nation meets The
Bachelor international and fan favorites
like Dino Gertz Eric bigger Ben Higgins
and Ashley Iook Annette er bundled up
and looking for love they'll compete a
fall in love and they'll fall all right
we promise winter tears weird just last
month
Ashley told easy she wanted the show to
be about friendship are you on the hunt
for love right now would that be a
reason that you would maybe go I don't
know and I really want them to highlight
friendships because from what I know it
seems like the American team is really
small so it's not like we're gonna not
know each other we all basically know
each other and I think it's maybe about
mingling with other countries and who
knows but longest relationship is you
get paired up with one of those guys
just being cozy in the cabinet hanging
out with like some of my closest friends
and drinking some and just means by the
fireplace all cozy I'm very much looking
forward to that if I'm going bachelor
creator Mike Fleiss initially said Peter
Krause was joining but he's not there by
the looks of it though we'll get to see
Trista and Ryan Sutter show up et was
also of Dean just before the cast took
off to Vermont here's what he said I
gotta ask you bachelor Winter Games yeah
you guys leave tomorrow or those who are
doing it to leave tomorrow are you
looking for love yeah absolutely I hope
I mean yeah we all are right Christina a
lot of fans out there still rooting for
some sort of reconciliation anything is
possible right but I don't know we both
care a lot about each other so I would
say that's you know never never close
the door fully on anything I guess
[Music]
you
[Music]